головною причиною депортації це те що ти
був українець тобі давали дві години
зібратися і навіки покинути рідну землю
за моєю спиною пам'ятник депортованим у
Львові але ми знаємо що депортованих
розселяли по всій Україні і о 14-му році
коли прийшла Московська орда сюди Вони
почали наново депортовувати і тих
нащадків депортованих тих часів але так
само депортовують і сьогодні не тільки
цивільних але дуже-дуже багато дітей
комуністичний режим
тоталітарний режим ті які здійснювали
злочин депортацію українців за Херсоні
мають бути засуджені щоб вони більше
ніколи не повторювалися у майбутньому
тому користаючи з нагоди я звертаюся до
президента України до Верховної Ради
України винесіть нарешті на голосування
в другому читанні законопроект 2038 які
засуджує депортацію українців за Херсоні
і визнає це злочином проти українці